the last thing the last thing we need is
neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask forget it
back in march the president scolded
texas for getting rid of its mass
mandate and opening up the state 100
since then
cases and hospitalizations have been
plunging and texas reported zero covert
deaths on sunday
governor greg abbott responding today
at this point in time we will never
declare victory however
it is interesting i still have not yet
received a phone call or
an apology from the president all the
liberals and all the media in the state
of texas
issued the same declaration some people
said that i had issued a death warrant
the people on the democrat side they
want to push narratives whereas what i
was looking at was
both math and science you know jesse i
think that was the most infuriating
thing nearly everybody in the media
who they attacked they often would bill
as murderers or
they had blood on their hands they went
after desantis falsely on a number of
smears
they uh what anybody who talked about
the viral leak they were called racist
trump had blood on his hands texans had
blood on their hands
meanwhile they were protecting people
like cuomo
do you think that they will actually
apologize jesse
no i do not gregory gupfeld
and you can just say biden had blood on
his hands too and you go back a year ago
he was against the travel ban
right if he was president how many
americans would have died from that
he wanted to lock down longer how many
more businesses would he have crushed
he was against school openings at the
time against sports reopenings
he cast a lot of doubt on warp speed and
raised a lot of suspicions which led to
a lot of people
hesitating so he was wrong with masks
too i mean
almost every little quadrant of this
last
cycle he's been wrong on but the media
paints him as this guy that follows the
science i just think he's kind of
looking for answers as he wanders
blindly around
update on the electric car deal in china
we're going to say it's mostly true with
some caveats
a company neo has sold more cars
that are electric than tesla but they
cost 70 grand
and they get huge subsidies from the
communist chinese government
and are produced in a region known for
unfair labor
practices so slave labor i was right
also also the coal plants that they're
building
generating the the electricity i'm right
again
i think i should leave now while i'm
ahead i'll see you guys later
so dana dana uh is
governor abbott guilty of what i like to
call neanderthal privilege
he's essentially flaunting texas's
extraordinary simple common sense and
our faces
and we have to suck it up yeah and i
it's actually interesting when he raised
this morning
that he hadn't received a phone call you
think like actually the joe biden before
the
white house he might have actually made
that call yeah and
and it would have been beneficial to him
he wants to get this infrastructure bill
done
he's got democrats he doesn't have
enough democrats probably only has 45
democrats right to pass it right now so
he's got to look for some republican
support
why not call somebody like greg admin
like you nailed it man
and congratulations on that keep it up
we're going to be following suit hey
while i have you on the phone can i talk
to you about this i think just do a
little politicking around here greg
yeah you know uh degan i think that's
why
this is just me hypothesizing and since
i was right in the previous block i'm
probably right now
you could probably bet on i'm always
right i am i can't help this
this is i think this is the reason why
president joe said that
all 50 states are declaring a decline
because he had to wait for the blues to
catch up with the reds
in his way so he could blur the gaping
gulf in success
the whole country's doing well but he
couldn't he could he that he couldn't
just say wow the reds are doing way
better
right those neanderthals really knew
what they knew what they were doing
but as a southerner i completely expect
this
because people will always underestimate
you
and think you're stupid quite frankly
based on where you're from and the way
that you speak but then you get to i'm
kind of a sore winner
i wouldn't take it as as nicely as
governor abbott did i'd have been you
know
doing a little dance but they but you
get to step back
and when you're right and you start
winning you can just watch their
pomposity melt into horror
but uh one just one more thing what
jesse was saying
and to your point earlier here's what
joe biden said
yesterday about mask he's still saying
this he said
the science now shows that your
vaccination protects you as well as
being masked
what what what or better than being
masked
since anyway i'll shut up it's okay
you know it's amazing juan i sense that
like when i'm looking at
how great the republican governors have
done dewine desantis abbott
and then you look at the democrats gavin
newsom cuomo they suck
this has got to just this is not going
to be good for the democratic party in
the long run
i might i just might pack it in juan
yeah it's just like you on the giant you
and jesse on the chinese electric cars
yeah we should all pack it in
uh you know i just think you guys are
spiking the football a little early here
and
of course that's texas bravado i love it
but it's you know you just have to look
at the numbers and realize things are
getting better
nationwide and things are getting better
in texas
but last week according to the numbers
coveted deaths dropped 11
nationally but in texas they were up 7
so you have to you know let's you know
they had a one day
with no deaths and god bless them thank
you but let's not pretend like oh yeah
you know texas is doing so much
better than everyone else
hey jesse let me finish jesse stop i am
so tired of you doing that
let me finish biden made that
neanderthal
comment uh i think it was march 2nd
since then we've had 6767
deaths in texas from covid in new york
and i know you guys love to beat up on
cuomo we don't have since march 2nd only
50
only 1500 1500 fewer deaths
uh with the mass mandate i mean and also
right now
texas is near the bottom when it comes
to vaccination rates so maybe
we should put some needles in those
neanderthal arms
uh because i'd love to congratulate
texas on the idea that we
they are now you know one day leading
all of us in the right direction that's
where we could say
congratulations to texas all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else